ADAM MARTIN: So
today, we're going
to continue with genetics.
And we're going to
talk about the rules
or laws of inheritance.
I expect that many,
if not all of you
have been exposed to
these rules before.
And so what I really
want to do today
is make the connection
between these laws
and the behavior of
chromosomes, such
that when you're thinking
about genetics and inheritance
pattern you're thinking about
chromosomes undergoing meiosis.
And I wanted to start just
to make the point that there
are a number of human traits
and human diseases that show
clear inheritance patterns.
And what's shown up here is
what's known as a pedigree.
So this is a pedigree.
Let's block this off.
I'm showing you a pedigree,
which shows relationships
and a family tree.
And so what you can see--
what these symbols denote
are, you have an open box.
That is an unaffected male.
So open box is an
unaffected male.
And what I mean by
unaffected is usually
it means they don't have
the disease that we're
talking about.
Circles represent females.
And so an open circle would
be an unaffected female.
And finally, if you have
one of these symbols,
either male or female,
and it's shaded in,
that, by convention, represents
an affected individual.
So that's an individual that
has the disease or trait.
So this is an
affected individual.
example of a disease
that you've already heard
about from Professor Imperiali.
This is a family tree
that's indicative of a type
of inheritance that's seen in
families with a disease called
phenylketonuria.
And you'll remember from
Professor Imperiali's lecture,
this is a disease where there's
a mutation or allele in which
there is a defective enzyme that
can't process the amino acid
phenylalanine.
And so patients
with this disorder
have to be very careful
about their diet
such that they don't intake
too much phenylalanine.
And what you see about
this trait or disease
is that it's skipping
multiple generations.
And then it manifests
itself down here.
I'm not getting any arrow.
So I'm just going to
use this pointer here.
So here you see there
are several individuals.
There's a male and a
female with the disease.
And it results
from a relationship
between two first cousins.
So only in this case does
the disease sort of appear.
And you can think of this
as a recessive trait.
In this case, it's
autosomal recessive.
So for PKU, this is
exhibiting what's
a type of inheritance known
as autosomal recessive.
And the reason
that it's recessive
is because if an
individual just has
one copy of a
functional enzyme, then
they don't have the disease.
So you can see that it's
only individuals that
have both defective
versions, which
are labeled lowercase a here,
that exhibit the disease.
So in the case of PKU,
lowercase a represents
the defective enzyme.
And uppercase A denotes
a functional enzyme.
Now, it's not shown
here, but it's possible
that an ancestor sort of
above this parental generation
also exhibited this
disease, such that there'd
be a sign that this is being
inherited across generations.
So that's not as obvious
in this disorder,
because it's a very
rare genetic disorder.
But more common disorders,
such as color blindness,
show a more clear inheritance
from generation to generation.
So is anyone here colorblind?
I ask just to know how to
set up my slides as well.
No one's colorblind.
OK, that's good.
Then you'll all see the
difference between the image
on the left and the
image on the right.
So if you have
normal vision, that's
what you see on the left
from this fruit stand.
But for those that are
missing the red photopigment
in your cone cells, you
exhibit color blindness.
And this fruit stand would look
like the image on the right.
So this is a clear example of
an inherited trait in humans.
And this is an example
of an inheritance pattern
that would be similar
to human colorblindness.
And here you can
see a clear example
where you have an affected
individual, an affected
male here.
That male has five
daughters, none of which
exhibit the
phenotype or disease.
But several of those daughters
give rise to progeny, sons,
that have the disease.
So in this case, you see this
trait skips a generation.
But essentially, the grandfather
here has passed on the trait
to his grandsons.
And so colorblindness is a
little bit different from PKU,
not only in the fact
that it's more frequent--
so it's about 10% of males
exhibit colorblindness
in the population.
But also you see with
PKU you had both a female
and a male affected.
And in this case, you're
seeing a preponderance
of affected males, which
seems to be not random.
And so this colorblindness
exhibits a different type
of inheritance pattern, which is
known as sex-linked recessive.
And I'm going to come back
to this inheritance pattern
at the end of the lecture.
Because it's actually this
type of inheritance pattern
which helped researchers
about 100 years ago
make the connection between
the unit of heredity
the gene and chromosomes.
So we'll talk about
another example
of this type of inheritance
pattern at the end.
So for today, what we're
going to talk about is
we're going to start with
some of the basic laws
of autosomal inheritance.
And so we're going
to talk about Gregor
Mendel and his seminal
studies in the pea plant.
And then towards the
end of the lecture,
we're going to talk
about sex linkage.
And I'm going to tell you
about work done in fruit flies,
and specifically, their
eye color trait, which
led to the linkage between
the behavior of genes
and the behavior of chromosomes.
So that's what we have
in store for today.
So first, I'm going to tell
you a little bit about what
enabled Mendel's theory.
I guess I could start over here.
So what enabled Mendel's theory?
And I presume that most of you
have heard about Mendel before.
So there might be a little
bit of a reminder for you,
but I also hope
that we kind of make
a very clear connection
between Mendel's theory
and the behavior of chromosomes.
So Mendel did his seminal
studies using the pea plant.
And one aspect of
pea plant biology
that was really essential
for Mendel's theory
is that you can both
self-pollinate pea plants,
meaning you can take the
male gametes from a pea plant
and mate it to the female
gametes from the same pea
plant.
So it's entirely
within the same plant.
So you can self-pollinate,
meaning you do a cross--
you basically cross a plant
to itself, which, obviously,
we can't do with humans.
You can't do with
many organisms.
Or you can
cross-pollinate, meaning
you take the male
gamete from one plant,
and you combine it
with the female gamete
from a different plant.
And as we go through
Mendel's experiments,
you'll see how this
was used to define
the rules of inheritance.
Another property of the
pea plants and something
that Mendel took
advantage of was he
chose traits of pea plants that
exhibited a very clear dominant
or recessive phenotype.
So he used visible
traits, visible traits
with a very clear
dominance or recessiveness.
And if we go back to
our example of PKU,
you can see how this human
disorder, the genes that
determine this disorder--
the alleles have a very clear
dominance or recessiveness.
The dominant allele is often
denoted with a capital letter.
In this case for PKU, you
we used capital letter A.
Or in this case, the disease
allele was lower case a.
And that's recessive.
And if an allele has dominance,
what that essentially means
is that being homozygous
for the dominant allele
is equivalent to having just
one copy of that allele.
And so I think if you
think of the PKU example,
this is very clear.
Because the disease
phenotype results
from a defective enzyme.
So if you just have one copy of
the enzyme that's functional,
then the human can have wild
type or normal function.
So in order to really lack
function of this enzyme,
you need to be homozygous for
the non-functional allele.
So you need to not have any
normal copy of that enzyme.
Because if you just have one
copy of that enzyme, you're OK.
Because you have
an enzyme that's
functional and will
carry out that function
in the cells of your body.
The last point I want to make is
that Mendel did his experiments
starting with what are known
as pure breeding lines.
So he started with
pure breeding lines.
And what I mean by
pure breeding are
these are lines that if
you take these plants
and just self-cross them over
and over again, generation
to generation, they
will only give rise
to plants with
traits that reflect
the parental generation.
So there's basically
no variation.
And you'll see in just a
moment that another way
to denote pure breeding means
that for a certain trait
you have an allele combination
which is homozygous.
So another way to think
of pure breeding lines
are these are plants that have
a homozygous allele composition.
Homozygous meaning
that either they
have two copies of one allele or
two copies of the other allele.
I just want to make
the point that Mendel
had to overcome a
number of hurdles
in order to get these results.
And Mendel is not
exactly your sort
of clear example
of a success story.
So Mendel applied to get
a teaching certificate
in university.
And he failed out.
And I'll quote one of his
instructors who said, I quote,
"He lacks insight and
the requisite clarity
of knowledge."
So that guy feels stupid.
So next-- so Mendel
did his experiments.
And the significance
of his work was never
recognized throughout
his lifetime.
He did his experiments
in the 1850s and '60s.
He died in 1884.
He died not knowing at all what
the significance of his work
was.
Because his work was then
found again in the early 1900s
by the likes of Thomas
Hunt Morgan and others.
And they made the connection
between Mendel's laws
of inheritance and chromosomes.
And it was really
then that Mendel
became the father of genetics.
Because then there
was a physical model
for how inheritance was working.
But he died before
that happened.
So he didn't realize that he
was the success that we now
know him to be.
Another interesting story.
He started his work with mice.
He wanted to breed mice
with different coat colors.
But he got in trouble
with his bishop,
because his bishop didn't
approve of him promoting sex
among these mice.
Luckily, his bishop didn't
take a plant biology course.
Because of course,
plants also have sex.
But he had to under come
a number of hurdles.
But he took advantage
of his garden.
And I was talking to someone
in my lab the other day.
And she said, you know
what's great about Mendel?
He had a garden.
And he just didn't
put it on Instagram.
So he used his garden
to his advantage.
And so with his
modest garden, he
came up with what are now known
as the rules of inheritance.
And I'll start with
Mendel's first law.
So Mendel's first law
is that every adult
has a pair of genes
for a given trait.
And these are now what
we refer to as alleles.
And we now refer to
them as genes as well.
Mendel did not
use the term gene.
He just had these abstract
sort of units of heredity.
So his first law states
that, every adult
has two sort of units of
heredity that can be different.
And that they split during
the formation of the gametes.
And the probability
that a gamete
will have a given
allele or a given unit
is equal probability.
So what I hope you can see
is that this law, which
is stated up there,
is a direct result
of the segregation of homologous
chromosomes during meiosis 1.
Mendel did not know that.
But now looking back, we can
see how this manifests itself.
And so during
meiosis 1, you recall
that the homologous
chromosomes here
line up at the metaphase plate.
And they line up
opposite each other,
such that some of the gametes
will get the capital Y
allele shown here.
And the other half
of the gametes
will get this lower
case y allele.
So there's a 50%
probability of a gamete
either having one or the other.
And of course, in
meiosis 1, this
is referred to as a
reduction or division.
Because the
homologues are split.
And so the genetic
content of the gametes
are divided in half.
So Mendel's first law,
the evidence for it
were the results of what is
known as a monohybrid cross.
So Mendel did what is known
as a monohybrid cross where
he took pea plants that
were pure breeding for two
different traits.
One was their pea color.
So it's yellow peas
versus green peas.
And he made a hybrid where
he takes a yellow plant that
arises from yellow
peas and crosses it
to a plant from a green pea.
And this is known as
the parental generation.
And so the result of this
cross is that all of the peas
were yellow.
So 100%.
This cross results
in 100% yellow peas.
This is known as the first
filial generation, or the F1.
And that should indicate to
you which of these traits
is dominant.
Because if you take yellow peas
and you cross it to green peas,
and you get yellow
peas, that means
that the trait for
yellow peas is dominant.
So for the rest of this, I
will denote the gene allele
that confers yellow peas
as capital Y and the gene
allele that encodes for
green peas as lower case y.
And you see what I'm doing here
is I'm putting the phenotype--
I'm describing the
phenotype there,
which is just what the trait is
that manifests in the organism.
But the genotype, which
is the combination
of alleles in the organism, I'm
showing beneath the phenotype.
And if these gene
alleles are splitting
during gamete formation
and then recombining
during the formation of a new
plant, then, in this case,
this hybrid plant
is going to have
one allele that's capital Y and
one allele that's lowercase y.
And because these two
alleles are different,
this situation is
known as heterozygous.
So this is a heterozygous plant.
You can think of pure breeding
being analogous to homozygous.
Because if you cross
yellow pea plant to itself,
you will only get
back yellow peas.
So it breeds true.
You can think of
a hybrid as being
equivalent to heterozygous,
because there are two gene
alleles.
So then what Mendel did
is he didn't stop there.
He's self-crossed
or self-pollinated
these F1 plants and looked
at the resulting seeds.
And so in the F2
generation, what he found
is that he got back both
the parental phenotypes--
so 75% of the progeny were
yellow, had yellow peas.
And 25% had green peas.
So there is this
3-to-1 ratio here.
Now, if we think about this in
terms of Mendel's first law,
where there's a
segregation of these
alleles during the
formation of gametes,
and there's an equal
probability of having
either one of these alleles--
if we think about
this cross here,
these plants, both the
male and female side,
are producing gametes that
are either big Y or little y.
So this would be
the female here.
And so because
they're separating,
and there's a 1/2
probability of having
either the capital Y or
little y allele for the male--
and there's also
a 1/2 probability
of having either of these
alleles for the female.
So if you look at the possible
combination of gametes
that could give rise
to the F2 generation,
you have some that will
be pure breeding yellow.
And the probability
here would be
the joint probability
of having this gamete
and this gamete,
which is one quarter.
You then have two
classes here that
have one copy of
the dominant allele
and one copy of the
recessive allele.
So these will have
the same genotype.
And these three will
have the same phenotype.
They'll all be yellow peas.
And so if you add up the
probabilities of all three
of these, you can see
that 3/4 will be yellow.
So 3/4 of the progeny will
have the yellow phenotype.
And you can see that another
quarter of the progeny
have the chance of getting two
copies of the recessive allele,
and therefore will be green.
So just by considering this as
a probability problem, which
is what Mendel did,
you can explain
the ratios of the progeny that
Mendel observed in his crosses.
And I want to point
out the parallels
between this simple
cross with peas
and the inheritance
pattern shown by PKU,
or phenylketonuria.
So notice here you
have green peas
in the parental generation.
But green pea skips a generation
and only appears again
in a subsequent generation.
So that's a lot
like PKU, where you
can see there's multiple
generations that
go by where the trait
doesn't manifest itself.
But then it pops up again in
that later generation where you
have inbreeding in this family.
So there's a clear connection
between the results that Mendel
got and cases of human disease.
Now we're going to go on and
talk about Mendel's second law.
So Mendel's second
law, which is often
referred to as the law of
independent assortment.
And another fortuitous
thing in thinking about
Mendel's experimental design
and setup which was fortuitous--
he didn't know it at the time--
he chose traits
that actually were
present on different
chromosomes of the pea plant.
So the traits
didn't exhibit what
is now known as linkage,
where they're are physically
connected on the chromosome.
So this law of
independent assortment
can also be explained by
thinking about how chromosomes
behave during meiosis, where
the alignment of homologous
chromosomes at the
metaphase plate of meiosis 1
is essentially random.
So if we take a look
at this example here,
you can see I've drawn one
particular configuration
for the chromosomes.
And I'm using sort
of one gene pair here
and another allele pair here.
And so if the chromosomes
were aligned this way, then
when they segregate
during meiosis 1
you'd get two
classes of gametes.
Some that are
capital Y, capital R.
And another class that's
lowercase y and r.
So that's one possibility.
But what's equally probable
during the alignment
of chromosomes during meiosis 1
is that the chromosomes line up
like this.
So rather than having
the dominant alleles
all on one side of
the metaphase plate,
you have a dominant allele for
one homologous pair on one side
and the other dominant
alleles on the other side.
So how they arrange, how these
homologous chromosomes arrange
during meiosis is
totally random.
And if they arrange
like this, you'd
get alternative
types of gametes.
You'd get gametes that are
uppercase Y, lower case
r, and lower case
y, uppercase R.
So this law of
independent assortment
can be completely explained by
the behavior of the chromosomes
during meiosis 1.
So now I'm going to take you
through the experiment that
illustrated this.
And this type of
experiment is what
is known as a dihybrid cross.
And so a dihybrid
cross is now a cross
where you're taking plants that
differ in two traits rather
than just one.
So di stands for two.
And in this case, we're going
to consider both pea color.
Again, the pea colors
are yellow and green.
But now we're also going
to consider p shape.
So you can have peas that
are round and peas that
are wrinkled.
All right, I'm going to make
use of this board again.
So let's consider the
round wrinkled case.
If you set up a cross
between a plant that
was from a round
seed and a plant that
was from a wrinkled seed--
and let's say the round
allele is dominant,
what would you expect
to see in the F1?
So you have-- yes, Carlos.
AUDIENCE: All rounds.
ADAM MARTIN: You'd see
all round, exactly right.
So let's go through,
now, this cross.
So we're going to have a
parental cross where Mendel
took two pure breeding lines.
One of them has
yellow round peas.
And he crossed the plant
from a yellow round pea
with a plant that was derived
from a green wrinkled pea.
And we already know
yellow is dominant.
And as Carlos just pointed
out, if round is dominant,
then you'd expect all of the
peas to be round as well.
So in the F1 generation,
what Mendel found is
you have 100% of the progeny
that are yellow round peas.
And then similar to
the monohybrid cross,
Mendel self-crossed
these F1 plants.
And by self-crossing
them, he observed
a number of different
classes of progeny.
So he got back the parental
types, yellow round.
He also got back this other
parental type, green wrinkled.
So these, because these were the
same combination of traits that
were present in at least
one of the original parents,
are known as perennials.
They're parental.
They had the same
parental phenotype as one
of the original parents.
But what Mendel observed was
two other classes of progeny
which were different
combinations
of these traits that weren't
present in the original
parental generation.
So those were yellow wrinkled
peas and green round peas.
So you'll notice that this
combination of traits,
yellow and wrinkled,
is not present
in the parental generation.
This is all F2.
This is F2 continued.
You also see green
and round were not
present in the
parental generation.
So these are referred to
as being non-parental.
So this non-parental class
is a unique combination
of traits that wasn't present
in the original parents.
And what Mendel noted was
that in these dihybrid crosses
he always got a stereotypic
ratio of 9 to 3 to 3 to 1
for these different classes
of combinations of traits.
Now we have to think
about the probability.
What leads to this
characteristic ratio?
And again, we can
think about this just
in terms of probabilities
and these different gene
pairs segregating
independently of each other.
So we already talked about for a
monohybrid cross for pea color,
3/4 of the progeny is yellow.
Because they at least have
one dominant allele for color.
And one quarter are green.
So the probability of having
this phenotype is 3/4.
The probability of being
green is one quarter.
And you can consider pea shape
as just a separate monohybrid
cross where the dominant
phenotype is also
going to be present
at 3/4 probability.
So 3/4 are going to be round.
And one quarter is
going to be wrinkled.
So now if we just consider these
different classes of progeny
here, we can consider
two monohybrid crosses.
And what's the joint probability
of being both yellow and round?
So the joint probability
of being yellow and round
is 3/4 times 3/4.
So if we have 3/4 times 3/4,
that's going to equal 9/16.
Now, if we consider
yellow and wrinkled,
that's the joint probability
of 3/4 and one quarter.
So this probability
is being 3/4 times
one quarter, which
is equal to 3/16.
Green and round is similar.
There's a quarter
probability of being green
and a 3/4 probability
of being round.
So again, you have
one quarter times 3/4,
which equals to 3/16.
And the least probable class
is being homozygous recessive
for both alleles.
Because there's a one
quarter probability of being
recessive for each.
So the joint probability of
having all recessive alleles
is one quarter times
one quarter, or 1/16.
So you could draw a
massive Punnett square
and also derive this.
But really you can
just consider it
as two separate
monohybrid crosses
and then just calculate
joint probabilities.
Any questions on Mendel
before I move on?
I'll just point out one thing
about Mendel's second law.
This is a rule that I'm going
to break, now, in just a minute.
And this law of
independent assortment
assumes that there
is no linkage.
In other words, seeing this
type of inheritance pattern
really depends on the
two genes not being
physically connected to each
other on the chromosome.
Now we're going to
talk about fruit flies.
And specifically,
we're going to talk
about a certain trait
in fruit flies, which
is their eye color.
I brought some pets
to class today.
And so we're going to talk about
the white mutant phenotype,
where the fruit flies
have a white eye color.
So I have three
pairs of vials here.
In one of them, there's
the white mutant.
And you're going to
see it has white eyes.
And then there's also
a corresponding sort
of normal red-eyed
flies in the other vial.
So I'll just pass these around.
Hopefully there's enough light
that you can see the eye color.
You're able to see
the eye color, Jeremy?
Yeah.
You might have to
come up to the board
lights at the end of class if
you want to see it really well.
So we're going to fast forward
from Mendel now and talk
about researchers who
picked up on Mendel's work
in the early 1900s.
And specifically,
I'm going to tell you
about research done in the
lab of Thomas Hunt Morgan, who
had a fly lab at Columbia.
So we're going to talk
about Thomas Hunt Morgan.
And actually, we're
going to focus
a lot on work done
in Morgan's lab
in the next couple of lectures.
Because it turns
out his lab also
made the first genetic map.
And we'll talk about
that in Friday's lecture.
So the type of inheritance
that Morgan defined
is what is now known as
sex-linked inheritance, where
a given trait isn't a sorting
independently of an organism's
sex, but is somehow
connected to it.
And I want to sort of
return your attention
to this example of
human colorblindness
where there appears to be
some sort of connection
between the disease phenotype,
in this case, colorblindness,
and the gender of
the individuals.
So you see this disease
is only affecting males.
And this type of
inheritance pattern,
while observed in
humans, is really
explained by work done in
flies on this white mutant
that you're carrying
through the class.
So sex-linked inheritance, the
explanation for that is this
is a trait that's carried by
a special type of a chromosome
known as a sex chromosome.
So fortunately, for
us, flies, like humans,
have a similar set--
or male flies and humans
have an X and a Y chromosome.
So the inheritance kind of
is similar between flies
and humans when
considering sex linkage.
And females have two X's.
So the presence of
these sex chromosomes
was known in the fly.
And it was known that if a fly
had an X and a Y chromosome
it would be a male fly.
And if a fly had
two X chromosomes
it would be a female fly.
And normally, normal
flies have red eyes.
But Morgan's lab was interested
in variation in organisms.
And they searched and
searched for flies
that had abnormal
characteristics or traits.
And what they found in
Morgan's lab was a mutant fly.
It was a spontaneous mutant.
But this fly had white eyes.
And it was male.
So they found a single
white-eyed male,
which they continued
to study for some time.
So they sort of defined some of
the rules of its inheritance.
So what Morgan and
his lab did was
they set up a set
of crosses that look
a lot like Mendel's crosses.
So you have a white-eyed male.
They took a white-eyed male.
And they crossed this white-eyed
male to a red-eyed female.
And if you cross a white-eyed
male to a red-eyed female,
the result was actually similar
to what Mendel had predicted,
which is that 100% of
the flies had red eyes.
So that's similar
to what you would
expect from a monohybrid cross
where red eyes is dominant.
So I'm going to refer to
the red eyed allele as an X
with a capital R. And
the white-eyed allele is
an X with a lower case r.
Because this gene is
present on the X chromosome,
but it's not present
on the Y chromosome.
So the Y chromosome
is really small.
And so the X chromosome has--
all of its genes are
basically present in one copy
in the male.
And that's going to manifest
itself in that sex linkage.
So then they took
this F1 generation
where you have red-eyed males.
And they crossed siblings.
So they did a sibling cross.
The one failing of flies
as a genetic system is they
can't self-cross.
You have to have a
male and a female.
So they crossed two individuals
in this F1 generation.
And what they found--
again, similar to what
Mendel would predict--
is that 75% of the
flies had red eyes.
And 25% had white eyes.
So this is behaving a lot
like the yellow trait in peas.
Except that all of the
white-eyed flies in this F2
generation--
all of these white-eyed
flies were male.
So only the males were getting
this trait of white eyes.
And you can see that that's
very much reminiscent
of colorblindness, where
you have a grandfather that
has white eyes.
And the grandfather
is essentially
passing on this trait
to his grandsons.
So this pattern of inheritance
that happens in the fly
is very similar to that
that happens in humans.
So now let's think
about how this--
if we can explain
this by thinking
about chromosome segregating.
So if we think about
this F1 generation,
we have red-eyed males--
or actually, let's do
the parental cross first,
where we have white-eyed males
and we have red-eyed females.
So all of the females are going
to get their X from their dad.
And they're going to get a
wild type copy of this gene
from their mom.
So all the females
are heterozygous
for the white gene.
So I'm going to call it the
white gene because that's
what it's called.
In flies, they name the genes
based on the mutant phenotype.
So if you mutate it, and it
results in white-eyed flies,
then they call it
the white gene.
All the males are going
to have a functional
copy of the white gene.
And thus, all of these
F1 flies are red-eyed.
So now these siblings are mated.
All the females are
heterozygous for this gene.
The males all have a
functional copy of the gene.
So they're going to make
gametes that are either
an X that's functional for this
eye color or the Y chromosome.
So now what you see is
that all of the females
are going to get this normal
copy of the gene from dad,
and thus, are going
to have red eyes.
Whereas half the
males are going to get
a functional copy from mom,
and therefore, have red eyes.
But the other half
of the males are
going to get this
non-functional variant that
can't produce red
pigment, and therefore,
are going to be white.
So this here is
your white class.
And you can see because males
only have one X chromosome,
the only class of progeny that's
going to be white-eyed here
are those males that occur
with a quarter frequency.
One thing I want you to think
about over the next couple
days--
and I'll sort of
take you through it
at the beginning
of next lecture--
is what would happen if you
set up a reciprocal cross here?
What if you mated red-eyed
males to white-eyed females?
And I want you to tell me
what you expect would result.
So my question for
next Friday is,
what if you took red-eyed
males and mated it
to white-eyed females?
So I want you to
think about this.
And I want you to think how
this is different from Mendel's
experiment.
What if you did a reciprocal
cross for, let's say,
the pea color?
How would these two
different crosses
compare with each other?
And we'll talk about that at the
beginning of Friday's lecture.
And we'll also talk about
the first genetic map,
which was actually created
by an undergraduate.
So stay tuned for that.
See you on Friday.